[Musique]
fatima et hakim décide d'aller à
copenhague au danemark et leurs agents
voyages propose un vol avec une
correspondance à paris de seulement 40
minutes
le jour du départ le premier avion
décolle en retard à cause d'un bris
mécanique et le deuxième est déjà parti
lorsqu'il s'intéresse à paris le
transporteur leur trouve un autre vol
plusieurs heures plus tard
mais ils perdent une précieuse journée
de leur voyage ou retour fatima les
crimes considère que le temps prévu
entre les deux vols étaient insuffisants
et peut être indemnisé
est ce possible chaque cas est unique
dans ce cas ci ils ont écrit retardé par
un bris mécanique
quoi qu'on en pense un bris ne libère
pas toujours un transporteur de sa
responsabilité
plusieurs lois et règlements peuvent les
aider parce que l'agent de voyages a le
devoir de vous conseiller et le
transporter dans le devoir de vous
amener à destination le fin mot de
l'histoire
il ya certains imprévus qu'agent et
transporteurs doivent prévoir